chuckle please explain how working
harder for an incompetent superior helps
oneself
I feel like screw them and whatever
lightning bolt of luck they were struck
by it again in their position that kinda
like screw them and the horse they wrote
in oh yeah that is no he's saying screw
them and they they were there they're in
their position of superiority cuz they
got lucky yeah yeah I didn't get all
that screw them yeah and you know here's
the answer that is like okay so what do
you do that okay what do you do then
you're gonna sit around and wait for
your own bolt of lightning of luck to
hit you is that what you're gonna do I
don't recommend that instead I I
recommend that you step up and yes you
do work harder and you do the best
possible job that you can do and you
take some pride in what you're doing and
how you're doing it and you do it better
than they could not to rub their nose
into it not to prove that you can do it
better but out of professionalism that's
why you do it now one outcome that can
come from that is they get credit for
your work and that makes y'all mad no
that's actually good because if they get
credit for your work that's what works
going well they're gonna get promoted
and they get the recognition okay that's
fine but but they know where the actual
credit goes even if they don't give it
to you even if they don't give it to you
they know it even if they're the type of
person that doesn't even realize that
you're like oh wow I did all that work
and he's taking all the credit for they
don't even know that I made this happen
or he doesn't even know that he that I
made this happen they know they know so
as long as you can keep your a you go
and check and you can let them have the
credit eventually they get promoted the
team's doing well you'll look good
you'll get promoted your life is easy
you're gaining experience you've got a
good reputation like everything is going
in your direction
and and by the way when that incompetent
person does get promoted who do they
usually recommend that fills their spot
you cuz you're the one that got them
promoted they're stoked on that now you
become a superstar
that's great eventually they're gonna
get found out by the
way like someone the incompetency can't
be hidden forever and eventually someone
says wait a second you don't even know
how to do this
that was that was echo Charles I was
doing this this whole time yeah okay
okay well we're gonna promote echo
you're out of here that that'll happen
and when that happens when that
incompetency gets found out then you
will get the recognition you deserve
because people said how that wasn't
Jocko doing all this stuff this was Echo
mm-hmm they go oh ja kou you're done so
that's so that's something to happen or
another outcome that can happen is that
they give you the credit that that
you're due which is great and you still
get promoted and you may get promoted
above them which is fine too
oh and or they might get promoted which
is fine stop worrying about it
so those two things if you do a good job
eventually something good is going to
come out of it whether it's they get
whether it's you both get promoted
whether it's they get promoted above you
whether it's you get promoted above that
it doesn't matter all those outcomes or
maybe it's just the team continues to do
well and your job is stress-free and you
continue to perform and and the the the
division that you're in grows and you
get a chance to promote because
everyone's gonna promote it's like all
good all good stuff or you can be angry
and you can be frustrated and you can
blame your own bad luck and you cannot
work hard and you cannot do a good job
and you can be recognized as a slacker
you can get blamed by the incompetent
boss when things do fall short because
that's what the incompetent boss does he
doesn't step up and say go ownership of
it he says no you know what I would have
done a better job but echo was slacking
that's the problem
now echo gets fired and and guess what
someone that we hire someone else to
come in and they start doing a good job
that boss still gonna look good okay and
still good promote it's just that you
lost your job and by the way you lost
your job with a bad reputation now you
can't even get a recommendation for a
new job so you lose that's what's gonna
happen
yeah so step up do your best it'll pay
off in the long run yeah it's funny how
like it's one of those things where if
you can just flip the switch and see
that just think and it's funny though to
the way those go the way these questions
are framed you know what they want to
hear is like no you know what if you got
an incompetent boss you don't help him
out yeah
burn yeah that's what you do that's what
people want to hear it but it's it's the
easy answer and it's not the smart
answer and it's a short-term answer not
a long-term answer you make your boss
look great how's that that's my goal I
want to make my boss look great you know
there there was little tell in the
question - I'm no expert obviously but
lightning bolt of la la yeah so you know
the whole deal and this is even you can
be a known person to recognize this like
people who are bitter I'm not saying the
asker of this question is good I'm not
saying that I'm saying this is a
external scenario but you know if you
get a bitter person who's just better in
life maybe not doing as well in life as
they had you know had hoped or whatever
you'll probability-wise
you'll probably encounter them from time
to time some more saying how the guy who
is successful is lucky they're lucky
they had a given to them like all this
all this other stuff me I'm not lucky
whatever whatever but it's always the
second successful guy is lucky always
yeah they attribute other people's
success to lock to luck for her so the
lightning bolt of luck and screw them
you know kind of thing just that is
indicative I'm not saying it is I'm not
saying it is or isn't as far as this
particular person but it tends to be
like that and again like that just that
switch if you can like turn on the
switch and just look at it just like how
you said it's not intuitive I get it man
it's like they say I was in that
situation we're like literally I was
doing the work so me think about this
you just said you're in this situation
almost everybody has been in the
situation and here's the difference
if you don't flip that switch and you're
in this situation your whole life goes
down in the other direction yeah that is
real problem that's why you meet people
yeah you know this is a thing I think
about a lot of you you know how you you
know people in your life they're
badasses but they but they're not going
anywhere like like you look at me go man
this guy's smarter than me and and a
better athlete than me and a better
speaker than me
but they're not going anywhere and you
know why it's because at some point in
their life instead of saying oh wow that
guy's
that guy's lucky that's what they do at
some point their life instead of saying
hey that person worked to get in that
situation and I should do the same
instead of saying that they say that
person got lucky yeah that's why they're
there and I'm down here yeah yeah you
can't make the upward climb if you don't
say you know what hey that person might
be a little luck there but guess what
they're obviously working hard they're
obviously doing something right because
I'm down here and they're up there how
do I get up there yeah the answer to get
up there is not by tearing them down the
answer to get up there is by working art
yeah make them look good that the line
you said what and so what are you gonna
do about it yeah what are you gonna do
but that's the switch right there cuz I
mean you deal with it with kids I've
seen some young kids and you know same
thing like oh oh it is or this happened
or whatever spilled milk I don't know
whatever and you know the kids crying
it's all this stuff's like okay so what
are you gonna do about it
so you can cry you totally can and you
can complain about how junk that is that
the milk that's spill to your toy broke
or whatever the situation yeah cuz
that's all true that's absolutely true
and go ahead you can cry or whatever but
if that's what you're gonna do about it
then okay then that's what it's gonna be
and that's all it's gonna be I'm gonna
continue to cry and you'll probably
continue to cry next time it happens too
or you clean up the milk you fix your
toy whatever you know whatever what are
you gonna do about it that's the living
you know what are you gonna do but it's
interesting to you there's like just a
known the the right answer seems really
obvious when we talk about it right now
but not many people see that right
answer no most people want to just be
mad at their boss and be frustrated and
undermine them and not work hard so that
they don't get any shine on them like
okay great that's you putting yourself
in that barrel - yeah don't do it
actually I shouldn't say it's crazy it's
it makes sense I mean I felt that before
100 percent yeah oh for sure sure